[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина
Лисичанськ]
Я побачив, що старші діти 15-19 років
не мають, де подітися.
У них немає можливості для самореалізації
в таких містечках, як наше.
Приїхали дівчата з «Кодом Міста»,
робили дослідження щодо міфологеми міста,
які є субкультури у місті тощо.
Знайшли хлопців, які займаються BMX...
[Максим Трунов
Координатор центру «Дружба»]
...в них була така проблема,
що вони каталися на площі,
а їх звідти ганяли,
бо вони по фонтанам стрибали.
І дівчата шукали для них приміщення.
Знайшли ось це.
Це — зала кінотеатру,
яка ніколи не працює.
Пішли до мера і запитали:
«А чи можна його хопцям взяти?»
Він сказав: «Добре».
Так буває, насправді.
Це наш скейт-парк.
Це таке немаленьке приміщення.
І ми намагаємося з нього зробити
місце, як ми проголошуємо,
«Простір неформальної
атлетичної культури».
Скейт-парк відвідують
за тиждень близько 100-150 людей.
Вже тут були діджейскі «паті»,
приїжджали хлопці, щось грали.
Було прикольно.
Загалом у нас на сьогодні 8 людей.
Є партнери, долучалися волонтери.
Люди, що працювали під гаслом:
«Ми будуємо собі дім».
Таке місце, щоб воно було прикольне.
Щоб тут було безпечно, цікаво,
щоб тут щось відбувалося.
З часом так воно і буде.
До третьої години, доки діти на навчанні,
це — коворкінг.
До третьої — коворкінг,
після третьої — вільний простір.
Тут буде, звичайно, кіноклуб,
будуть навчальні програми різноманітні.
Це ще одна зона відпочинку буде.
Вже ми купили кава-машину.
Ми плануємо зробити тут намет
і буде така лаунж-зона.
З класним видом і на завод, і на місто.
Для сучасної молоді
можливостей дуже багато.
Я їм показую канали в Telegram
про можливості. Кажу:
«Дивіться: стажування, обмін, волонтерство.
На рік у Іспанію, наприклад».
В нас також тут будуть
вечори української мови.
Бо я зараз спілкуюся з вами українською,
а у повсякденому житті я спілкуюся російською.
Між іншим, можливість
поспілкуватися українською,
не привертаючи до себе «косих» поглядів,
це дуже добре.
Коли мова не використовується, вона помирає.
Окрім українських вечорів,
тут будуть english-клуби.
Мене надихає «ВІЛЬХА» —
«ВІЛЬна ХАта» у Краматорську.
Дуже надихає.
Хочеться, щоб і в Лисичанську
було таке життя.
Щоб відбувалися ті речі, які я бачив.
Щоб було як в «Теплиці» в Слов'янську.
Це прикольно.
Зараз є сильний запит молоді
і таких дурних, як я, щось робити.
В нас існує конкуренція
між Лисичанськом і Северодонецьком.
Северодонецьк — обласний центр.
Купа якихось ГО, активностей,
завжди там щось проходить, відбувається.
Через річку — Лисичанськ, і тихо.
Коли ти вже тут живеш
і не плануєш нікуди від'їжджати,
чому б не спробувати зробити щось цікаве?
Щоб це було місце таке унікальне,
щоб сюди приїжджали з велих міст...
[Андрій Харьковський
BMXер, активіст центру «Дружба»]
прилітали з Європи.
Щоб не ми до їхніх парків кататися їздили.
До Барселони, де найкрутіші парки,
всі хочуть потрапити.
А треба зробити так,
щоб усі до нас хотіли приїхати.
Все реально.
Якщо до чогось йти —
це здійсниться.
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Ольга Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]